they'll know date we always disappoint
people with that question talked about
having babies yesterday but I'm not
pregnant I'm drinking wine but that
doesn't mean Caitlin's not keeping busy
she was just on The Bachelor at Canada
after show and she has some very strong
opinions on drew the contestant who is
quickly becoming Canada's very own Chad
Johnson I walked the fine line between
confident and cocky
drew is cocky it's kind of a jerk
unfortunately yes he is the villain and
I don't I don't love how he behaves
until I'm trying to give like yeah
perfectly correct answer yeah yeah you
can finally let me know and the couple
try to keep it politically correct when
they are grilled about Nick becoming the
next Bachelor we haven't watched this
season I don't like well start now we
did we honestly just wish him luck we
can't forget Catelyn famously breaking
Nick's heart during her season of The
Bachelorette and choosing Sean instead
I didn't know like who could beat The
Bachelor who is best fit for the
bachelor so nothing really surprises me
in that world and it got people talking
so they know there didn't work